this looks like some uh ultimate fire
contestant just lost something
at least wannabe hey fio hey brendan
i got a king i will sting it for your
shout out brendon's uk
grandma from london what do you think of
brands
them hot fire tattoos this is meant to
be an anarchy
but i got it facing the wrong direction
by accident
what's the problem
london buzz gang boy shout out to london
baby
shout out sheffield bro what's up i'll
be out there soon
shout out sheffield bro shout out
sussex you know okay
liverpool stroud shout out
shut up west stains bro eat any stains
what you know about that sunderland son
huh
you don't know [ __ ] this dude's talking
about getting burned instead of getting
tapped shout out york
sunderland's tony jeffries right yeah
that's where tony jefferson is from
mm-hmm
shout out york dude show us where
peppermint patties are from
they're delicious i always wish they
made them thicker though dude i'd like a
lot more cream
i don't think i think they're perfect if
you don't have time to brush your teeth
i have a york peppermint patty and hit
the road
that's fair same thing do they still
make them huh
why don't they ever make them thicker i
can't be the only one who wishes there's
more cream in those things write another
letter dude i'd love to have the
original letters burning wrote to places
again yeah right into the library yeah
eventually they come
yeah oh come on guys
half inch of thickness
you guys got the wrong idea man come on
half inches i wish it was half an inch
sounds great uh [ __ ] brands do you know
about that
hurt to get [ __ ] branded like a cow
on your arm son
did people on your football team do it
yeah
it's a definitely well what do you know
about a spell it happens a lot of the
black community i feel like in the
future
fraternities yeah they do like omega pi
fi do you have any friends that have
ever had it
no i don't know anyone that's got it my
dad's got a
stab wound same thing from prison
similar to frat yeah 17 years in prison
shout out to osb
shout out boy i talked to him he made it
out but i guess i wonder how they do
that if there's a yeah yeah
there's one right there that's that
omega and then they they always do this
yeah okay brendan
oh you don't want to say that yeah
you're wearing red
no it's soon
i think we both do bro i do
my [ __ ] looks hype dude i posted a young
picture of me on my instagram and
someone said i look like the chuck e
cheese rat
let's see no they look turned out there
go to the originals bro
the originals were real ratchet they're
made out of carpet
were they yeah uh where's it at
it was uh david lucas david lucas shout
out to david
right there right there right there
david lucas someone said you've grown to
them chompers
[Laughter]
holy smokes boy you gotta do barbecue
now
i know right yeah what were those books
too were we all reading
those are fake books that's just why
people keep referencing apple
because there's an apple if you move
down to right there
so put that so everyone's like it's in
danger
yeah just live my life that's the gap
tooth goblin right there baby that's my
nickname yeah dude goblin brothers
yeah barbecue gargoyle for me i don't
know yeah man now let's see the animal
they're referencing
that chuck e cheese yeah let me see that
busted ass chuck e cheese
i [ __ ] hate chucky cheese yeah but
you know
they went bankrupt son huh yep yeah
somebody will bail them out
yeah someone will maybe you two should
nope
forget that the zoo in sinaloa
bail them out yeah i i could do one
establishment but
i'm not getting into a whole chain of it
not the chucky i'd rather do one food
truck
oh okay remember we're gonna do that
that uh pokey truck
i think that [ __ ] was fantastic it'd be
fun to have a
food truck look at that [ __ ] rat
why you pull up that one i think that's
the closest yeah
that's not bad dude
there's been a lot of chuckies over the
years too he started out
really different you heard the origin
story of chucky's there he is right
there go to the right neck
a little bit no with your mouse laugh
right there oh wow
oh gosh looks like brian catch that one
he has brian kellen's eyes
um
[Laughter]
it's still not that close but
same positive energy you know yeah bro
have you ever heard of uh the chuck e
cheese origin story
the the owner of chuck cheese came out
and gave the origin story you know chuck
e cheese
was developed he decided to throw
parties for kids because he didn't have
any friends
so the only way he could get kids to
play with him is by selling parties
wow and the e stands for entertainment
charles entertainment cheese
fax man yup
[Music]
is